[Musique]
ils ont fait ça parce que ils reprochent
au prince Charles d'avoir tenu des
discours contre le réchauffement
climatique pour le climat pour la
planète et de ne faire rien comme ils
attaquent des tableaux de peinture mais
qui sont protégés en disant plus de
pétrole ou en disant intéressez-vous aux
vraies choses moi je trouve que ce sont
des démarches salutaires
ils ne détruisent pas les hommes ils
sont formidables ces gens là
on peut dire pourquoi ils ont fait ça
donc on ne retient que là qu'on ne
retient pas le pourquoi voilà
c'est vraiment ça il y a pas d'autres
mots comme elle même pas calme-toi
pardon c'est vrai que c'est agaçant
quand même c'est les symboles qui sont
importants que ce soit l'art que ce soit
la monarchie que ce soit la fonction
qui a été fait aussi vous avez vu que là
il y a eu
la première fois
alors
[Musique]
de fond tu balances de la purée
en fait je peux comprendre il prône pour
la défense de l'environnement etc il y a
pas pour ça même là-dessus mais en fait
à un moment donné tout simplement il
faut comprendre si ils veulent entamer
de telles démarches qu'ils entame des
grèves de la fin par exemple qui se
mettent devant le ministère de
l'écologie directement qu'ils entame des
grèves de la fin qui suspendent à des
poteaux j'en sais rien qui fasse autre
chose mais personne pour personnellement
je cautionne absolument pas ce genre de
choses alors il y a ma sœur qui réagit
il commence à me casser les couilles
avec leurs conneries voilà donc et vous
avez vu dans une que dans une concession
d'une voiture de d'une marque de luxe de
voiture il y a eu encore quand même des
activistes comme ça alors ils se sont
mis autour des voitures ils se sont
collés les mains au sol et dans le
concessionnaire le patron de la marque
en fait lui il a carrément dit que ça le
saoulait donc il a éteint tout il les a
laissé et pendant 40 heures ils sont
restés la main collée manger sans boire
en faisant dessus etc ça pouvait même
être grave pour eux donc ça va susciter
des réactions aussi
ça risque de les entendre
marre des écolos aussi il y a déjà pour
dire j'en ai marre des écolos parce
qu'ils font n'importe quoi en fait on
est on est bien sûr qu'on est pour
l'école la planète bien sûr mais on va
tous essayer de sauver la planète mais
on va pas la sauver en trois quart
d'heure donc à faire des trucs comme ça
[Rires]
tu as envie de te dire ils font chier
les écolossa c'est comment ça à faire
chier le tableau est prêté il vaut 111
millions d'euros c'est un tableau qui
est prêté par un milliards il a porté la
Castaldi à son grand-père ils savent
très bien qu'il est protégé il n'attaque
pas le tableau comme ça ils savent que
symbole mais voilà ils attaquent un
symbole et je trouve ça hyper
intelligent regardez on en parle à une
empreinte on parle de l'AC